الآن تعاني مدينة زاباريسيا
مرة أخرى من هجوم صاروخي روسي
أصاب فندقًا كان أيضًا بمثابة
معسكر يومي للأطفال، حيث سقط صاروخان يوم
الخميس بعد ساعة فقط من
مغادرة الأطفال لهذا اليوم، كما أفاد نيك بايتون
والش عن إحدى الضربات  تم
التقاطه بالفيديو،
الضربة الأولى جلبت الرعب،
ضرب فندق ريفرسايد هذا الرجل مع
عائلته وهم يتجولون في حديقة زابا ريجيا
في الساعة 7:20 مساء الخميس،
رعب ثم قاعدة أخرى ترصدها الشمس
أولاً
[موسيقى]
كما لو أن الفندق الذي استهدفوه كان فيه
أطفال  كان المخيم قد انتهى
قبل ساعة واحدة فقط وكان لا بد من ضربه مرتين،
تخيل كيف شعر الأطفال في
مسبح الفندق بعشرات الضيوف
الذين أصيبوا بجروح ولم يبتعد أحدهم، هكذا
بدا الأمر قبل أن يضرب الاثنان
صواريخ فضيحة على حمام سباحة
وملعب في  موقف سيارات
شكرًا لك،
أعلن مسؤول روسي بعد ذلك أن جميع
الفنادق في المدينة أهدافًا قائلاً
إنها مليئة بالجنود الأوكرانيين بعد
عدة ساعات من انطلاق صفارات الإنذار في كييف، ولم
تتمكن أوكرانيا إلا من إسقاط واحد
من أربعة مسؤولي صواريخ كينجال التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت
قائلين إن هدفًا آخر كان
منشأة تدريب F-16 في الغرب
هذه الضربات الليلية رد روسيا
على الضغط على الجبهة الجنوبية
حيث تم تحقيق مكاسب صغيرة يوم الجمعة، وقد
حث الرئيس زولينسكي على الصبر
والتحرك يوم الجمعة لتثبيت سفينة بطيئة الحركة
تطلق رؤوس
التجنيد العسكري الإقليمي  بعد سلسلة من
فضائح الفساد، تم استبدالهم بالمحاربين
القدامى الجرحى
الذين فقدوا أطرافهم الصحية
لكنهم يحافظون على كرامتهم
وليس لديهم السخرية، ويمكن الوثوق بهم
لإدارة النظام في أوكرانيا.